o que ensinava fazer esta pergunta é
enquanto dirigia por aqui
no entanto o esta chance ímpar bicam é
palmas obra como quero faça só agora é
eu não sei bem se a uma pergunta se a
máfia mas ela é esta fotografia é muito
bonita não é e eu sou espanhol como é
óbvio mas na realidade acho que é uma
fotografia muito bonita responder esta
pergunta a segunda já tem mais
dificuldade conseguissem o que é mais
bonito ainda que esta tecnologia era
mais bonito que esta fotografia onde
estava dentro do avião volta
era realmente uma tentativa de vida é de
quem é que eu me sentia muito mais à
vontade lá dentro da alguns obstáculos
em diz leco água ou me contar uma
história de aviões uma história de
aviões que formavam a patrulha da força
aérea portuguesa
estava a chiar do sangue 5 em março de
1975 é meu parte das pessoas que se
encontra não viveu é nova e mas ouvi
contar a situação
a situação que se iria nessa altura eu
cheguei no governo de moçambique contigo
e quando cheguei a lisboa muito longe
não percebi que é aquilo que nós não
tínhamos informação bastante longe e
moçambique
quando cheguei cá vive situação e vivia
devia hop khan em dois ou três dias
depois desse gado e fui colocada pela
base aérea de sintra para comandar as
quadras desde 1977
ei quando verifiquei que o panorama lá
dentro não era muito diferente daquilo
que se viria cá fora causa autêntico eu
entrei na voz e som a via twitcam sorria
comício só ouvia forma agrária top dos
tops reforma agrária grande entre as
pistas cultivavam levava-se terra havia
monitar e civis com enxadas terra semear
o plantar com suas ruas os senhores que
se lhes pede que o painel
acho que não estava fazendo um trabalho
foi fugir
o gênio numa das pontas da base e um de
star wars quadra queria ser da minha
responsabilidade e fui pra lá estava
afastado de problemas maior fã na
esquadra
o que que ele aconteceu xilai para mim
com mais dois problemas dos 30 aviões
que força ele tinha destes 30 aviões 37
para formação de pilotos só um é 41 39
estavam avariados dos vinte e tal alunos
que estavam lá para fazer o curso
estavam lá há um ano ainda não tinha
praticamente começado a voar decisão
imediata junto à sintonia disse
repetindo agora e nós não vamos cumprir
o horário da base nós vamos voar muito
mais cedo
nós vamos acabar muito mais tarde o
avião não se encaixam e aliás nós
sofremos que enquanto mais vôos de
aviões - deveria está empreendendo uma
faca chá e entrou nós dividimos por tudo
isso foi em curso e avançando por isso
incrementar o tópico em tópico pensasse
que era possível fazer um curso com um
único avião com muita urgência junto dos
dois manutenções tanto lá dentro da base
como em ao ver que eram as oficinas de
idade da retaguarda da força aérea no
sentido de convencer aquela região já
aprontaram envia hoje próprio curso
avançasse
mas na altura zera quiser conquistar
vagas importante não podia chegar lá ao
pé dos tucanos com esse visual militar e
dizer você me desancando certeza entrou
em campo temos que trabalhar porque eu
preciso ter a via espera mudar o curso
pelos dutos formarem não não era
possível instrumento então a região os
segmentos tolos se o dono do primeiro
que rejeite foi assim juntamos um nome
junta em alguns indivíduos que estavam
lá arquivar reforma agrária e disso está
muito me realmente a forma grave é muito
bonito mas nós temos que arranjar uma
alternativa e alternativa porque como
vocês sabem
a escultura atraem os passos de espaços
são um grande perigo para a aviação
isso é dura entre cabeça qualquer dia
nós temos uma data dizer passa dos em
trapos 11 onde o avião cai morta
embalamento caiaque em cima de você
estão a trabalhar
morre mais gente e então é uma desgraça
total funcionar isso funcionar e foi
comum este tipo de argumento em sintra
em alverca que prontidão dos aviões foi
melhorando
quando chegou a um ponto do curso eo
andamento normal foi que nós entramos no
fundo objetivo no trajeto da formação da
formação do da patrulha e tudo começa
assim muitos de nós outras forças aéreas
mas sobretudo muito bons muito bons
motivos
só que os vôos não queriam prejudicar
quem são estes não era prioritária e
portanto só podemos voar durante a
semana depois de ter os partidos da
instituição ao fim de semana sábados e
domingos e pará na base e também
estávamos completamente liberto para
fazer durante todo o dia os voos de
treino que quisesse e depois de vários
vários novo êxito tanto num cantar só
para dizer que quem sofria mais um como
estarão as nossas mulheres porque nós
ficávamos sozinhos mas nossas mulheres
acompanhavam as mulheres têm uma
vantagem muito grande é que elas eram os
grandes críticas aquilo que a gente
dizia nas um ponto de vista técnico da
pilotagem off mina mas supõe ponto de
vista daquilo que é o efeito que
produziam as nossas manobras ele que
eram elas tentar me manter a assistência
mini nos dava as suas opções bom
o mundo de hoje com o rodrigo ea certa
altura antes tínhamos um livro nós
entendíamos nível técnico em vantagem
capaz de fazer apresentações públicas e
participadas mundo assiste vários selos
nacionais e estrangeiros
em teoria de tiririca - ao nível de
qualquer patrulha de qualquer outro país
nessa altura ensinar a escolher juntos
convite que já tenhamos nós só depois de
termos a certeza por 1 1 em inglaterra
era o primeiro como nesse ano morava
exclusivas de billy da rainha era um
festival que tem um prestígio montes em
grande e muitas forças aéreas de todo o
mundo e gravam seus organizadores civis
iemenitas a organização mista enredavam
se de todos em todos os festivais
representarem uma novidade
e eu queria apresentar ano visadas por
que vieram de muito longe para que nós
fossemos nós queremos e busque que tem o
festival
combinadas as duas coisas mas havia um
problema e que o vôo tem que ter pelo
menos para se perceber a manobra desenha
e fica no ar havia outros tínhamos que
ter o nome oficial é foi fácil
temos que ter uma atitude teve utilizada
por que o haviam sido eta não era muito
famosa no ar e então tínhamos que
inventar uma pintura que ninguém fosse
mais utilizada para esse efeito também à
boa maneira portuguesa
os pilotos dos instrutores e
distribuímos miniaturas de 37 que
compramos levem para casa
venha largas à vossa imaginação e de
tínhamos tempo a gente vai espiar de
pintura que vai mandar
após a oficina de pneus pintar na equipe
toda não era feito pelos pilotos mas
havia um problema mais grave que é o dos
pulsos
não que nós não tivéssemos capacidade
técnica de montar um sistema de fundos
mas porque há muito tempo não tínhamos
tempo para o festival para preparar
porque porque tem que ser todas abertas
e e compartimentadas outra maneira para
levar combustíveis diferentes conforme
fosse promotor deviam confrontos por um
fundo branco ou então meninas que
coloriam os clubes grandes
isso não dava tempo não dava tempo
tínhamos que arranjar fundos mais uma
vez a bandeira portuguesa e exames e até
o avião tem dois lugares lado a lado num
lado e assentado piloto no outro citado
um bidon mittal do gasóleo e foi assim
que nós foi bom
e lá fomos e fomos muito bem recebidos
muito capacitados até porque era usá-lo
vida e o filme toy 01 na grande de
visões do desgaste destaque com os atos
em todas as patrulhas no dia 11 o
festival no outro dia vi chamas
estiveram más e combinar não vai poder
visitar um hospital de crianças
deficientes porque o hospital
os fundos angariados na era um benefício
do hospital e então criam funções nós
depois novo gol do treino de exibição
tive fato visitar o hospital
nós fizemos quando entramos no hospital
às nossas divergências começaram a ficar
sem
eu não tiver um bom tempo seco o emissor
pontos ganhos o monsenhor bandas
portuguesas é silhuetas do avião era um
festival naquilo que o douro oranto mas
o pior ou melhor nos entendendo
conquista foi quando entramos nas
entregas nas enfermarias e vimos as
crianças nos aproximávamos delas e vimos
o estado delas mas elas estavam
insatisfeitos contente e essa alegria
passou para 9 porque nós estávamos a
sentir que estávamos em transmitir uma
grande alegria aquelas crianças e como
nossa mente uma maior alegria do que
aquelas transmitidas sonhos e sobretudo
de série são crianças são crianças
naquelas condições tanto elas ganhavam
menos uns fatos do lucro ficavam durant
foi o festival bom tempo eu digo que
aquilo que estva queira muito dejeto que
era um grande festival nós que estamos
muito encantados cambalhotas os aviões
o ponto alto foi a visita ao hospital
essa ficou parecendo um tempo ainda
muito não dá muito rapidamente sofre um
aqui no porto com mais de 100 mil
pessoas outro em frança em e no final se
fez o encerramento do festival os
patrulheiros todas eram os 42 aviões
voar juntos nos céus frança em cada uma
das patrulhas lançava nos seus fundos as
coisas nacionais que estava acabado
isso foi uma coisa absolutamente
maravilhosa em e pronto inclusive contar
mas é porque eu tivesse grande parte dos
meus amigos em que anuncia fazemos
sempre está prontinho enviada fase mas
como é que tu me apaixonasse por quilo
por que tu não fez o lado civil dizia
sempre exercer os soldados não tenho nem
quer perder porque os sucessivos soldado
a tristeza
eu quero recordar aquilo que eu fiz
aquilo que eu fiz com deu grande prazer
é isso que eram até porque quando eu
passei na força aérea em preto e dois
anos lá equivalente desta desta paixão
que muitas muitas outras paixões e oh oh
oh oh mesma intensidade que esta e se eu
fosse soldados e passar a estudar para
tristeza passava a vida a jurada e um
nome trocava mas pro dá nada em termos
profissionais é a vida que acho que o
surto o que é preciso é preciso o que é
preciso é é realmente em queda da altura
toda sua paixão eo agora também tenho as
minhas paixões tem aqui declaro aqui
faça o momento o bahia já não tem paixão
e na força aérea o melhor pelo menos 20
eu optei por viver numa aldeia israel
devia eslava muito bem sustentado lá e
então paixões de que eu tenho paixão é o
meu piano que cá está é mais uma
orientação e não dizem que pio e eu em
novo tive alguma ligação à música em que
gostou da minha música que ninguém da
palmas mas também não é pedir pelo bank
tó lancer câncer uma pessoa essa síntese
um tratado assim por pessoa
é o meu cão não quero gastar com certeza
eu tenho minha música quando eu vou ao
piano e no centro e levante também
centers e quando eu começo a tocar pelo
começa a dormir profundamente
profundamente obrigado
um golaço do zero o flex é sempre eu
quero acabar minha irmã que o trânsito a
virar campeão